this is the building targeted by
ukrainians on their devastating New
Year's Eve strike it was as you can see
a substantial School building where
hundreds of Russian mobilized soldiers
are thought to have gathered to
celebrate the evening
this is the same building viewed from a
satellite before and now after the
attack and film from this point here we
can have a look at footage taken in the
immediate aftermath
as you can see the missiles strike left
very little of the building just smoking
piles of rubble this is the weapon
Ukraine used to make the attacker U.S
supplied High Mars High Mobility
artillery rocket system it is
extraordinarily accurate within five to
ten meters and it let the ukrainians
destroy their target here in mckeevka
within Russian Hill territory from miles
away
unusually Russia has admitted the attack
happened but appears to have downplayed
it saying only 63 soldiers had died that
is disputed by Ukraine and Russian
military bloggers one former FSB agent
and high-profile blogger Eagle sirkin
claimed that the number of dead and
wounded runs into many hundreds and he
says our generals never learn from their
mistakes on Independent Russian Media
One soldier's wife is quoted as saying
that the wounded had to walk to hospital
some of them naked and otherwise said
some of the Dead were Torn to Pieces by
the blast and there was practically
nothing left of their bodies Russian
politicians are calling for military
heads to roll over the strike including
Member of Parliament Sergey moronyov
who's demanded criminal liability for
any officers who he says allowed the
concentration of military personnel in
an unprotected building
Ukraine claims 400 Russian soldiers died
in the high Mars attack and it says
it'll continue attacking more high value
targets
update from Russia's defense Ministry on
that they have now acknowledged that 89
Russia's Russian servicemen died in that
mcivka attack they also say that
officials responsible for the tragedy
which is being investigated will be held
to account and go on to say that
unauthorized use of personal mobile
phones was responsible for the incident
which allowed Ukrainian forces to
pinpoint their location the latest there
from Russia's defense Ministry